Hello everyone, my name
is Noah Chernick and
I'm here today to lecture
you guys on orthopedics.
We're going to go
through an introduction
and also concerns of
the upper extremity.
Once again, I'm one
of your academic
medicine scholars
for this year and I'm
really excited to
give this lecture.
Before we get started,
I quickly want to give a
special thanks to a few
of the individuals who
created this lecture
before me, Dr. Ferderman,
Dr. Joshi, Dr. Pinella,
and Robert Steinberg, who
is a former academic
medicine scholar, but most
importantly thank you to
Dr. Heller for allowing
me to collaborate with
him on this lecture and
for all the guidance
throughout this creation.
At any point during this
lecture, if you guys
have any questions
whatsoever or any concerns or
maybe comments about
the lecture, please feel
free to reach out to me.
We can discuss, we can
meet via Zoom. If you
and your study mates want
to meet in a group that's
also completely okay.
Anything to help you guys
understand the concepts more.
Here are our learning
objectives for today's lecture.
So before we get
into more specifics,
I want to talk a
little bit about our
general approach in
orthopedic concerns.
And like many other
aspects of medicine,
anatomy is going to be
extremely important. We
need to think about
the other issues in the
surrounding neurovascular
structures where our
dislocation or fracture
may be presenting.
We could see some
complications such as
avascular necrosis,
which is the death
of bone due to the
lack of blood supply.
You could have nerve
damage or entrapment,
compartment syndrome,
infection, more specifically
osteomyelitis, and
deep vein thrombosis.
When we're interviewing a
patient who presents with
orthopedic concerns, our
history really needs to focus
on the mechanism, right?
Is this an acute event? Was
this a high-impact trauma
that occurred 20 minutes
ago? or was this something
that was more non-contact
or is this a chronic symptom
or chronic issue that's
now presenting more severe?
It changes our clinical
decision making and our
thought process moving forward.
For physical exam, you want
to do a full musculoskeletal
exam and also include
relative special tests.
And then for diagnosis,
imaging will be a great friend
of yours, x-rays, CTs,
MRIs, and ultrasounds. For
treatments in general, you
want to start conservative.
RICE, the mnemonic rest, ice,
compression, and elevation,
has commonly been prescribed
for most orthopedic
issues. However, there are
some physicians and physical
therapists that kind of
sway away from this, but
that's a topic for another
day. And for right now, just
assume essentially conservative
treatment. You want to
control for pain, and you
could also move a little
bit more aggressive, being
joint injections. For this
lecture, we're not really
going to discuss surgical
techniques, but just understand
there are, you know, the
basic complex concepts being
fracture reductions using
nails, pins, and plates,
and sometimes this could
be done manually prior to
surgery or for dislocations.
So let's talk about some
basics of the bone before
we get more specific with
orthopedic concerns of the
upper extremity so for
anatomic locations the epiphys
is going to be the end of
the bone and in between
the epiphys and the metaphysis
we're going to see our
growth plate that metaphysis
is the flared portion
of the bone and then the
diaphysis is going to be the
long shaft i now want to
talk a little bit more about
fractures i know you saw
these terms on the previous
slide but it's always
good to have a visual age
so a transverse fracture
is going to be a clean cut
across, so kind of perpendicular
to that long axis. An
oblique fracture is going
to be fractured down the
long axis, so almost on
an oblique angle. Where a
spiral fracture, you want to
think of the trauma almost
in a twisting motion, so
it's a complex fracture
line that encircles the
shaft of the bone. A commuted
fracture is going to be
more than two fragments, so
if you can see here, we
count at least three, right?
So for E, an avulsion
fracture, you can
have a fragment of the
bone be torn off from
the main mass, as you
can see down here.
For an impacted fracture,
essentially the fragments
are driven into each
other, causing the bones to
wedge together. And then you
could also have a displaced
or non-displaced fracture,
right? A non-displaced
fracture, the fragments
are going to be aligned,
and a displaced fracture,
the fragments will be
separated. A compound fracture
is a type of displaced
fracture where the bone is
actually piercing the skin.
So we see a lot of these
orthopedic concerns and,
you know, we often hear a
little bit more about these
severe compound fractures.
So Chris Weidman back
in 2021 had a severe compound
fracture of his shin,
right? You can kind of
see the leg buckling here.
Alex Smith back in 2018
had again another compound
fracture in his tibia
amphibia and actually
developed a couple post
-surgical complications.
He had necrotizing
fasciitis. If you don't
know his story, it's
actually really, really
incredible that he came
back from this, he almost
lost his leg, and then
ended up playing again.
So you have two more terms
when we think about pediatric
fractures. A green stick
fracture is going to be
an incomplete fracture that
extends partially through
the bone that is usually
due to a bending stress. So
if you look at our green
stick fracture, we see a
fracture, but it's not going
to go completely through.
The bone will not fail on
the compression side. So it
will fail on tension side
but not the compression.
A torus fracture you'll see
more of a buckling sensation
or buckling appearance
compared to that fracture
so it's usually a cortex
that buckles on compression
and then the non-tension
side may fracture as well but
the big difference here
is you will see more of a
fracture on the green stick
and buckling on the torus.
So when we talk about
pediatric fractures we
also have a classification
system known as the
Salter-Harris and it's
actually a ranking or
scheme used to classify
growth plate injuries.
So type 1 is going to
be a fracture running
just along the growth
plate itself. Type 2 is
going to be a fracture
above the growth plate
and then it also runs
through the metiphysis.
Type 3 the fracture is
going to start lower
and then kind of come
through the growth
plate and run horizontally
and it almost creates
a right angle right
with it running through
the growth plate and
then the epiphysis.
Type 4 you can have a fracture
through the metiphysis,
growth plate, and epiphysis,
kind of vertically
on an angle, if you can see
up here. And when we get
to type 4, we start to
increase the risk of growth
arrest, right? We could
have an issue here with
damage to the growth plate
because there is a fairly
severe fracture. And then
type 5, we actually don't
have that obvious fracture
that you see in the types
1 through 4. It's more of
a compression force. But
with type 5, it's 100%
growth arrest rate. So the
growth plate is going to
be essentially obliterated.
And if you can see down
in the left-hand corner,
we have a little bit
of a mnemonic cell
salter, straight across,
above, lower or below,
to or through, and then
you can kind of think
type 5 is crush.
So moving on to compartment
syndrome, we first need to
understand that these skeletal
muscles throughout all
the body are kind of
contained within distinct
osseofascial compartments, and
compartment syndrome is due
to increased pressure
within these non-compliant
compartments. So we could have
two different types, acute
compartment syndrome being
much more severe, it is a
medical emergency, and it can
lead to permanent functional
loss. And it's usually due
to internal fluid, it's
either via hemorrhage or
edema that limits the space
of the neurovasculature,
or it could be external,
right, some compression or
traction on the limb, and that's
very severe. It's going
to increase the pressures.
Versus a chronic
exertional compartment
syndrome, it's usually
exercise-induced,
and it's not that
big of a concern.
Your common causes of
especially acute compartment
syndrome could be
fractures, most common
being in the tibial
diaphyseal fracture, and
then trauma and burns,
constrictive bandages,
and also animal
bites and stings.
For your clinical
exam, you have to
take and count the
entire picture.
So it's also a 5P
type of situation. So
you could have pain,
pain with any passive
movement, and that's
extremely sensitive.
So pressure, increased
tension of the
muscle compartments,
right? Compartment
syndrome is all about
increasing pressure.
Parasthesia, right?
This is more likely
due to ischemia of the
nerves, and it can be
irreversible if we
do not treat the
compartment syndrome and
relieve the pressure.
Paralysis, again, being
due to the nerve and
muscle damage due to the
ischemia, or it could
be due to inhibition
because it's so painful.
And then later on, you're
going to see pallor
and pulselessness.
Again, this increase in
pressure can cut off our
blood supply, creating
ischemia and decreasing
the capital A
perfusion. And the
treatment is a fasciotomy.
And again, this is something
that if someone presents
acutely with severe pain,
something to keep in mind.
So the last topic I want
to talk about before we
go into more upper limb
specifics is bursitis.
And a bursa, we need to
understand before we go to
bursitis, is simply a
lubricated, fluid-filled ***
that's adjacent or between the
soft tissues and essentially
just tries to reduce
friction between the
structures, such as the bones,
joints, tendons, and skin.
The pathophysiology behind
bursitis is these bursa
can become irritated or
inflamed, and they can
present acutely, typically
with pain and swelling.
If they present more
chronically, if it's ignored
until there's a more chronic
issue, you could see more
functional limitations
due to joint contractures.
Some of the causes
could be infection, but
more often, you know,
a chronic overuse or
maybe some underlying
autoimmune disorder.
So for your presentation,
it's going to be more pain,
swelling, and tenderness
near the joint. For acute,
it's going to be more pain
and functional limitations
over the course of a few
days, right? This should
present fairly slowly. It's
not going to be instantaneous
over a couple hours. If it
is something that presents
more rapidly over a few
hours, maybe think infection.
For chronic, the long-term
symptoms may be present
for weeks to months, but
it's nothing very specific.
And it actually,
bursitis can appear
fairly similar to
tendinopathy, right?
That includes tendinitis.
But a big difference is,
typically in tendinopathy,
you have pain that's elicited
with movement, where bursitis
is more pain at rest.
So the common areas for
bursitis, one of them we'll
talk about is olecranon
bursitis, but you can also
see it in the shoulder,
the knee, and the Achilles.
So we're now going to
move on to our first area
of orthopedic concerns,
being the shoulder.
So very quickly, just
to review our anatomy,
we have our shoulder
girdle, which consists
of our clavicle and
scapula. We have our SC
joint, which is the
only true connecting
joint for the shoulder
to the axial skeleton.
And again, we see a
lot of these shoulder
joints being ball and
socket. So we have increased
mobility, but with that
increased mobility,
we also have an increased
risk of dislocations
and sprains, increases
in instability.
Moving further away, we
have our AC joint, and it's
the only articulation
between the clavicle and the
scapula. And then finally,
we have our glenohumeral
joint, which has the
greatest mobility of all the
joints. But again, we're
going to sacrifice stability
for this increase in
mobility. And it is held in
place by the labrum, which
is dense fibrous tissue.
Continuing on, we have
our rotator cuff muscles.
Again, we've learned the
actions of these muscles
through anatomy, but we
also need to understand
that they are usually
active stabilizers of the
glenohumeral joint. They
help compress the humeral
head within the
glenoid, increasing the
stability without really
losing any of our mobility.
Just to review their
actions, the supraspinatus
initiates shoulder AB
duction, the infraspinatus
is an external rotator,
the teres minor also
does external rotation
with some AD duction,
and the subscapularis
is our internal rotator.
For shoulder abduction,
it's important to keep in
mind our range of motions.
So for 0 to 15, it's going
to be the supraspinatus.
For 15 to 90, the deltoid,
and then greater than 90,
a mixture of the trapezius
and the serratus interior.
These ranges of motion
do help us kind of
identifying underlying
neurovascular issues
as well as maybe
certain muscle defects.
Our first pathology we're
going to talk about is
shoulder dislocations, and
this is most likely due to
our instability of the
shoulder. We have excessive
translation of the humerus
over the glenolumeral surface
and we have both static
and dynamic stabilizers,
our bones and ligaments
being statics and our muscles
being dynamic that help
improve the stability of the
glenohumeral joint. However,
it still can be placed
in unstable positions so
when we're in abduction,
external rotation, and
extension as we can kind of see
up here, that does increase
our risk of an anterior
dislocation. So speaking a
little bit more specifically,
our anterior dislocation
is more common of the
two. The common mechanism,
again, the medial aspect
of the elbow, is hit while
the shoulder is abducted,
extended, and externally
rotated. You typically will
see two associated
lesions with this anterior
dislocation, and that's
mostly because the head of the
humerus will dislocate
anteriorly, causing trauma in the
joint capsule and labrum.
You're going to see a
Bancart lesion, which is an
anterior inferior capsular
injury associated with the
tear of the glenoid labrum.
You're also going to see
a Hill-Sax lesion, which
is actually a compression
fracture of the posterior
lateral humeral head. And
don't worry, I have a nice
image depicting both of
these on an upcoming slide.
And both lesions actually
increase the likelihood of
recurrent dislocations. For
presentation, The patient
may be holding the arm in
slight abduction, with the
forearm being held with
the opposite hand, and the
patient's typically unable
to internally rotate the arm.
You could also see a
dimple under the acromion.
For treatment, you want
to reduce the shoulder as
quickly as possible, and
then immobilize for two to
six weeks. Then you
typically want to start with
rehab and conservative
treatment, focusing on strength
training to help increase
the strength and stability
of those muscles, especially
the rotator cuffs.
If these measures fail,
then you could start thinking
about surgical options.
For a posterior dislocation,
it's a little bit more
rare, and it's seen more
in long-term shoulder
instability, and it's actually
commonly missed on imaging.
But one noticeable feature
is a light bulb sign, and
this is because the humerus
internally rotates with
posterior dislocation,
the glenohumeral joint
widens. So if you can
imagine here, this actually
somewhat looks like light
bulb. For presentation, the
arm is typically going to
be held with the hand on
the belly, and the arm
cannot be externally rotated.
So diving in a little bit
more detail to our labral
tears, the first one again
being associated with our
anterior dislocation. The
Bangar tear is going to be a
tear to the inferior rim
of the labrum. If you look
down here, this tear
typically likes to run on that
anterior and inferior side.
Some people may call it like
a three to six or three
to nine somewhat tear. The
mechanism is again due to
anterior dislocation and if
you can look down here it's
usually an avulsion of the
anterior capsule labral
complex below the midline and
it's also associated with
our hillsax lesion. We spoke
about that a little bit
earlier. That's the fracture
forming on that posterior
lateral side. For presentation
for symptoms it's again
going to be fairly non
-specific for anything shoulder
related popping, catching,
grinding, and locking.
It's also associated with
shoulder dislocation and
instability of the shoulder.
Continuing on to slap
tears, I want to quickly
just focus again on the
purpose of the labrum, and
just remember that it
is cartilage lining the
glenoid fossa, and it helps
stabilize the shoulder.
And it does this essentially
by increasing the
surface area for the
humerus to kind of connect
in, and it also provides
attachment for the
glenohumeral ligament and
the long head of the bicep.
For a slap tear, the longer
and more official term
is a superior labrum
anterior to posterior tear.
It actually tells us
where the tear is. It's
going to run on that
superior side of the labrum,
running from the front to
the back. The mechanism
can vary. It could be an
acute injury, but also
think about chronic
degradation in these patients.
Repetitive overhead motion,
especially in
throwers and swimmers.
Again, a presentation is fairly
similar to our
bank heart lesion.
Popping, catching, grinding,
and locking. You also
may see limited bicep
contraction, and this is, again,
due to the superior glenoid
acting as an attachment
for the long head of the
bicep. There are some special
tests you can do. Again,
don't worry about those
too much at this point for
this lecture's purposes.
For treatment, it's actually
unclear what the
ideal treatment is.
Typically, again,
you want to start
conservatively and
then maybe ramp up your
treatment to more
aggressive options.
Moving on to our
chromioclavicular dislocations,
the AC joint is also a
common area of injury,
and when we see dislocations,
it's usually due
to trauma to the shoulder
area with an adducted
arm, so we really
can't brace our falls.
You're going to see pain,
potentially loss of function
of the scapula, and then
tenderness over that AC
joint area with potential
step-off, as you can see
in this image down here.
For management, again, going
to be fairly conservative
and treatment-oriented.
It's going to be ice and
immobilization and a sling
for pain relief, and that
duration of sling and
immobilization can kind of
vary from a few days to six
weeks, depending on the
severity of the dislocation.
Talking about clavicular
fractures, it's actually
most common in children and
also seen in birth trauma.
The clavicular
fracture actually is
broken up by three
different sections.
So the medial third being
more midline, our middle
third, which is midshaft,
and then our distal third.
it's commonly caused by a
fall on an outstretched hand
or direct shoulder trauma
and most commonly we see the
middle third or the mid
shaft being fractured and
it actually presents a
shoulder drop and in a normal
clavicle if everything's
connected the scm muscle will
pull that shoulder kind
of medial and elevate the
medial fragment of the
clavicle but if we lose that
connection with the mid
shaft fracture we don't have
anything counteracting the
weight of the shoulder pulling
the lateral end of the
clavicle down. For treatment,
it's going to be a sling
and non-surgical approach.
Looking more into our
rotator cuff, again, we want
to think about our
innervations for each of them.
And again, remember the
supraspinatus is our most
commonly seen rotator
cuff injury. Overall, we
see all of these rotator
cuff muscles being innervated
by C5 to C6. When we
talk about attachments
are supraspinatus,
infraspinatus, and teres minor,
all being attached to the
greater tubercle of the
humerus. The subscapularis
is going to be the
lesser tubercle of the
humerus. So it's a little bit
easier if we just remember
the one outlier here.
The mechanism for most rotator
cuff injuries is actually
going to be a result of
acute trauma more often
seen in younger individuals.
In older individuals,
it's going to be chronic
overuse and degradation and
just in general we'll see
rotator cuff injuries being
in a older population for
treatment it's more conservative
management for partial
tears there's no actual
scene benefit for early
surgery in these individuals
for the rotator cuff tear
the mechanism is usually a
result of acute trauma or
chronic overuse the presentation
the pain can be located
in the anterior lateral
shoulder a big sign that
this could be a rotator cuff
tear is actually nighttime
pain they usually cannot sleep
on the side of the pain
for physical exam you want
to inspect for atrophy of
the supra and infraspinatus
muscles and you also want
to do active and passive
range of motion testing this
can actually correlate the
each action of each muscle
right if we remember the
actions of each if we see a
weakness in potentially our
internal rotation it could
point us towards a subscapularis
tear. You also can implement
your special tests,
which are the empty can
and drop arm, and we'll go
over those on the next slide.
For treatment, again, it's
more conservative management
for our partial tears.
If there is a more
severe tear or we have a
younger patient, we could
consider arthroscopic
surgical intervention.
However, in our elderly, we
typically move in a more
conservative manner.
for our special tests
you will go over these in
dpr as well your empty
can test so you're going
to take the patient's arm
essentially elevated to
shoulder level and point
their thumbs down like
they're emptying a can
if you see down here and
if it's positive if you
see weakness as you try
and push down on their
arms the positive test
will indicate potential
supraspinatus muscle tear
Our drop arm test is
essentially what the
name is. The patient will
elevate the arm fully
and then slowly
lower it. If the arm
suddenly drops or there's
severe pain, it again
could indicate a
supraspinatus muscle tear.
So moving on to impingement,
it's actually one of
the more common causes
of shoulder pain. This
includes pain caused by
rotator cuff tendinitis,
subacromial bursitis, and
also biceps tendinitis. For
the mechanism, it's
typically due to an anatomic
narrowing of the subacromial
space. somewhat irritating
some of these tendons
that I just spoke about.
For clinical progression,
we'll see edemia, then
fibrosis, and eventually
tendinitis, and you typically
see a history of repetitive
overhead activity.
For special tests, you'll
see a positive near
and Hawkins sign,
and again we'll talk
about these tests
specifically. For treatment,
typically for your mild disease,
it's going to be treated
conservatively, again with
price, and your symptoms
will typically resolve on
their own with more chronic
pain you can benefit from
cortisone injections around
the rotator cuff and even
more severe diseases can
require a surgical repair
including a where you typically
remove a small portion of
the acromion or the barca
to help relieve that pressure
so for our hawkins test
the examiner is going to
flex the humerus and elbow to
90 degrees and then maximally
internally rotate the
shoulder and apply overpressure.
So you're going to see
positive tests with reproduction
of pain in the superior
shoulder. So if you see the
image here, you're essentially
going to bring the elbow
out to an anterior position
and then internally rotate
or push that arm down.
For the nearest test, it's
going to be almost like an
empty can but a little bit
more flexion of the joint.
so the examiner is going
to stabilize the scapula
with a downward force while
fully flexing the humerus
overhead with overpressure.
Positive reproduction of
the pain in the superior
shoulder is a positive test.
And again, both of these
will test for impingement.
Moving on to adhesive
capsulitis, the pathophysiology
behind this is actually
poorly understood, but in
general you see fibrosis,
inflammation, and capsular
contracture of the shoulder
capsule, and there are two
types. The primary is typically
idiopathic and secondary
is actually due to a variety
of underlying conditions,
and it is responsible for
pathologic loss of motion
of the shoulder. So
individuals who lose both their
active and passive ranges
of motion in their shoulder
joint, you could be thinking
about adhesive capsulitis.
It tends to affect middle
-aged patients in their
non-dominant arm, and it's
commonly actually associated
with diabetes for presentation
it's going to be pain
on palpation of the anterior
and posterior capsule
and you'll see active and
passive loss of range of
motion for treatment
again fairly conservative
physical therapy and oral
medications moving on further
down the arm to the
humerus the first thing we
are going to talk about are
actually the fractures of
the humerus there are a
couple different ones that
we'll go over and before
we touch on each one of
them i want to keep some
general concepts in mind.
So again, the mechanism,
it could be a low energy
fall in some of our elderly
individuals, especially
those who are osteoporotic.
It could also be in high
energy trauma in younger
individuals. Our treatment,
depending on the situation,
could be surgical and
non-surgical. And as we
go through each of these,
I want you guys to keep in
mind a few things. First
off, which nerve is being
affected by the fracture?
What vascular structures are
compromised by the fracture
and finally what's the
clinical picture associated
with each fracture type and
we'll go through each of
these together again just for
your use we have the anatomy
of the humerus here
describing the different parts
we're going to be talking
about our surgical neck the
shaft as well as the
supracondyler and the epicondyle
starting first with the
surgical neck fracture of the
humerus the mechanism usually
seen in elderly individuals
due to a mechanical a
fall. It also could be due
to a direct blow or even a
violent muscle contraction.
Essentially, you also could
see this in an anterior
dislocation of the humeral
head. So if you see
a vignette or a patient
comes in with a dislocation,
you cannot rule out a
surgical neck fracture.
For damage, the nerve
usually in question here
is the axillary nerve.
Again, it's fairly
high up. And for the
vasculature, it's going to
be our posterior
circumflex humeral artery.
For presentation, this
usually has to do mostly with
issues in the axillary
nerve. So we're going to have
a flattened deltoid, as well
as loss of arm abduction
in the shoulder for anything
greater than 15 degrees.
And we're also going to
see a loss of sensation
over the deltoid and
lateral arm, and these
all have to do, again,
with the axillary nerve.
And again, looking on the
x-ray here, you can see
that small line fracture
in the surgical neck.
Continuing on, our mechanism
is going to be fairly
similar to the surgical
neck, direct blow, a
fall, or a collision. Our
damage, the nerve typically
in play here is the
radial nerve, and the
vasculature is going to be
the deep brachial artery.
For presentation, it's
going to be a loss
of sensation over
the posterior arm and
the forearm, and
also the dorsal hand,
all, again, having to
be innervated by the
radial nerve. You're also
going to see wrist drop,
no extension of the
elbow, wrist, and finger.
Again, if we can remember
what these nerves
do, especially with
the radial nerve, the
presentation will be
fairly easy to understand.
You'll also see a decrease
in grip strength because
we need our extensors
of the hand to do that.
This presentation is actually
going to be similar to
compression of the radial
nerve as it exits the
brachial plexus. As you guys
may have learned in first
semester, this is also known
as Saturday Night Palsy.
Moving further down
the arm to our distal
humerus, also known as our
supracondylar fracture,
The mechanism, usually
in pediatric patients,
this is going to be a
foosh, fallen outstretched
hand, with extension in
the arm. For our damage,
it's going to be for
our nerve, the median
nerve, and vasculature
of the brachial artery.
And as you probably could
have guessed, the presentation
is again going to be
mostly due to our loss
of the median nerve. So
loss of wrist flexion, and
the function of the
lateral two lumbricals, the
opponent's pollicis, and the
abductor pollicis brevis.
The median nerve again
you have to remember is
contributing to the
flexor compartment of the
wrist along with a little
bit of the ulnar nerve
but the median nerve is
our general flexor and
this actually may present
similar to our carpal
tunnel presentation but
we may see less flexion
of the wrist in the
distal humerus fracture.
So one complication to also
keep in mind kind of tying
two ideas together you
could see something called
Volksmann's contracture and
this is due to irreversible
ischemia and compartment
syndrome, and actually can
be the result of a
supracondylar humeral fracture.
Essentially what happens is
the swelling caused by the
fracture can lead to compartment
syndrome, which suppresses
the brachial artery,
leading to ischemia in the
forearm flexor muscles.
Additionally, we could lose
our median nerve, further
exacerbating the damage and
increasing the contracture
of the flexor compartment.
Over time, the muscles will
shorten and scar, contributing
to the contracture. And
for our presentation,
the fingers and wrists
will be flexed with passive
extension almost nearly
impossible of the affected arm.
Continuing on to our medial
epicondylofracture, the
mechanism again is usually
most common in pediatrics
due to a direct trauma. The
damage here is going to be
due to the ulnar nerve. If
you kind of remember your
anatomy on that median side
of the humerus, our ulnar
nerve will kind of run
under the medial epicondyle.
So we can imagine if we
have a fracture here we run
a risk of hurting or
severing our ulnar nerve. For
our presentation, if you
could have imagined, it's
going to be a loss of ulnar
nerve function. So paresthesia
in the fifth digit and
the medial aspect of the
fourth. We're also going to
have decreased grip sensation
because we lose flexion
in the fourth and fifth
digits, and it's going to
be similar to our cubital
tunnel syndrome that we'll
discuss a little bit later.
This is just a recap for
you guys. For our surgical
neck, think axillary and
posterior circumflex humeral
for our mid-chaft think
radial and deep brachial
for supracondylar think
median and brachial and
then medial epicondyle
think ulnar if you guys look
down surgical neck mid-chaft
supracondylar it actually
spells out arm if we
take the first letter of
each of the nerves this is
again a good summary slide
for you guys to come back
and just kind of reinforce
these things with you we've
talked about all these
things already this if
like images a little bit
more you can kind of help
solidify and reinforce some
of those concepts you had
in anatomy with innervation
and some of the actions
of each of the nerves.
Continuing on now to the
elbow, the first thing I want
to briefly touch upon is
elbow fractures and actually
identifying elbow fractures
is typically done with
the help of visualization
of the posterior fat pad.
So normally this fat pad
is pressed in the olecranon
fossa by the triceps tendon,
essentially making it
invisible on lateral
radiographs. However, when we
see a fracture involving
the elbow, that could be the
distal humerus or even the
radial head, the inflammation
and diffusion develops and
this actually increased
fluids will force the
fat pad out of its normal
resting place, causing it
to be visible on x-ray. And
this sign actually may be
the only visible marker of
a fracture, especially in
our pediatric population.
Moving now towards
dislocation again for elbow
dislocations the
mechanism will be trauma.
The anterior dislocation
is typically an anterior
to posterior force and
posterior is actually again
that fall on an outstretched
hand. We have two types
simple meaning meaning
no underlying fractures
and complex meaning we have
associated fractures. You
could also have associated
ligament tears, fractures,
and ulnar nerve injury.
Again you have to
remember how closely that
ulnar nerve runs underneath.
Tying back to real
life, this is an actual
image from Dr. Heller
when he was covering
one of his cage side
events and this was
an elbow dislocation
due to an arm bar.
A pathology that could
actually look similar
to an elbow dislocation
but you can actually
rule it out almost
immediately based off of
mechanism is elecronome
bursitis. So like I say
here, the presentation
can look similar to the
dislocation, but it's
all about the mechanism.
You'd expect a bursitis to
kind of be a more chronic
or slow occurring issue.
This wouldn't be a rapid
or sudden bursitis. The
mechanism still could be a
direct trauma or repeated
excessive pressure and
friction. It's common in
students, athletes, mechanics,
and plumbers, anyone who
may put a little bit more
pressure on their elbows.
treatment is going to be
fairly conservative rice and
avoidance of the aggravating
activity you could drain
the bursa if it does
become an issue you could
also have more aggressive
treatment such as corticosteroid
injections however if
there are any concerns for
a septic bursitis again
you have any reasons that
maybe this is an infection
you will draw cultures
when you drain the bursa in
radial head subluxations
this is also known as the
nursemaid's elbow The
mechanism is typically with a
child. If the child is
pulled rapidly up by the hand
or wrist, the radial head
could displace inferiorly
from the annular ligament,
and this is mostly because
our annular ligament in
children is still immature
and can slip out and over
the head of the radius.
For a presentation, you'll
typically see this in
a child, and they'll hold
their hand in flexion,
pronation, and adduction.
For treatment, you want to
reduce the radial head.
It's performed with marked
supination and flexion
and you'll typically hear
an audible pop. Once
it's reduced you'll see
almost immediate improvement
in the range of motion.
For UCL injuries also known
as the ulnar collateral
ligament which attaches
the humerus to the ulna,
there are three bundles
and the mechanism for this
injury is typically a valgus
force at about 50 to 90
degrees of flexion that
puts the most stress on the
UCL. We typically see this
instance or appearance
when we are at the peak
phase of acceleration of
throwing. So both in our
quarterbacks and our pitchers,
this is actually a common
issue. If anyone follows
sports and you kind of
understand what this issue is,
this is actually the infamous
Tommy John surgery. So
Brock Purdy, back in the
NFC Championship game a few
years ago, tore his UCL
injury. And for any Mets
fans out there, you probably
know who this is already.
Matt Harvey, back
in his day when he
was in his prime,
had a UCL injury
and never really
came back the same.
We're going to continue
down the arm to the forearm.
So starting off with
epicondylitis, we have a
nice little mnemonic up
in the middle of the page.
Tennis on the outside,
golf on the inside
is one of them, and
then also mega late,
mega being medial
epicondylitis with the golfer's
elbow, and then late being
lateral and tennis elbow. for
lateral epicondylitis we
want to think about extension
with this issue the mechanism
is usually associated
with chronic overuse of the
finger and forearm extensors
and this causes tendinosis
of the common extensor
tendon usually we see this
pain on the lateral epicondyle
and we want to think this
muscle group right our
extensors are innervated
by the radial nerve on a
physical exam if you could
palpate that lateral epicondyle
it could produce pain if
you also increase passive
pronation of the arm or wrist
flexion, or if we resist
active wrist extension,
we could see this pain
increase, and for any of these
tests, if we have pain near
the lateral epicondyle, we
should increase our thought
process about maybe this
is lateral epicondylitis.
For medial epicondylitis,
we want to think about
golfer's elbow, which is
essentially a flexed and
pronated position. So
the mechanism here is
essentially very similar,
but chronic overuse of
our wrist flexors and
forearm pronators. This
causes tendinitis on the
common flexor tendon at
the medial epicondyle.
The muscle that we usually
think here are flexors is
innervated by the median
nerve and for physical exam
if we palpate that medial
epicondyle with passive
supination of the arm or
if we extend the wrist or
if we resist active flexion
and we see pain in these
we think maybe this is a
medial epicondylar issue.
Continuing on for distal
radius fracture, this is
actually one of the
most common injuries in
orthopedics. Again, a fall
on an outstretched hand. We
see this through a couple
different mechanisms.
This common idea of falling
could cause a couple
different fractures. If
we see these in elderly,
we think about a higher
risk with osteoporosis.
And these images
here are actually
from Dr. Heller as
well of a distal
radius fracture in
one of the fighters.
Continuing on, talking about
cubital tunnel syndrome,
the mechanism here is
the ulnar nerve being
even trapped at the elbow
within the cubital tunnel,
and the cubital tunnel
again being about a two
to three inch long tunnel
near the medial epicondyle
where the ulnar nerve
passes through as it moves
into the forearm, and in
this syndrome the ulnar
nerve is compressed by
rigid connective tissue.
For physical exam, if you
tap over the cubital tunnel,
it could actually create
kind of electrical
shooting sensation, moving
down the ulnar distribution
of the hand, so again that's
our digits, the medial
aspect of 4 and then our
5 or pinky finger. We can
also have paresthesia in
digits 4 and 5, and we also
will see weakness of the
intrinsic hand muscles and
inability to flex the
digits 4 and 5, again due to
a weak flexor digitorum
profundus. This will be contrast
with Goyan's canal
syndrome a little bit later
on in this lecture, and
we'll talk about that then.
Continuing on to the wrist,
talking about fractures
of the carpal bones, we have
our nice little mnemonic
here for the eight bones
of the wrist, but we're
going to focus in on the
scaphoid, which is the most
commonly fractured carpal
bone, and the mechanism, like
we've seen in a couple
other injuries during this
lecture, is to actually fall
on an outstretched hand.
As you guys may know, the
scaphoid is palpable in the
anatomic ***** box, and
the risk of the scaphoid
fracture is actually the
avascular necrosis and the
nonunion, and this is because
the scaphoid is supplied
with a retrograde blood
supply from a branch of the
radial artery. So if you
look down here, we're
moving more distal from
the radius down into the
metacarpals. The scaphoid is
actually supplied from a more
distal aspect moving
proximal. So if we have a more
proximal injury of the
scaphoid or more proximal
fracture, we have an increased
risk of necrosis. For
physical exam, you'll see
pain in a limited range of
motion of the wrist with
pain on palpation of the
anatomic ***** box, and this
is a very sensitive exam.
You guys may know that x
-rays actually may have a
lower sensitivity for
identifying scaphoid fractures,
but if you are able to
palpate that ***** box,
it could lead to an
indication that maybe you need
further imaging, such as the
CT or MRI. For treatment,
if there's no risk of
an avascular necrosis,
essentially a more distal
fractures we want to cast
in a spica cast for up to
20 weeks again with this
retrograde blood supply it
can take longer for these
fractures to heal if we have
an increased risk of necrosis
or we have an athlete who
has some form of accelerated
return to play protocol
we may want to consider
more aggressive approaches
in surgery you'll actually
see a few clinical vignettes
and questions whether you
are looking at your in
-house exams or maybe in a
year or so when you're
thinking about boards about
individuals who come in with
arm pain after falling and
they have pain on the wrist
but the x-ray was clean so
scaphoid fractures are
often missed on your initial
x-ray so you actually want
to do repeat or further
imaging to see if there
actually is a scaphoid fracture
and again a big tell that
there could potentially be
a scaphoid fracture is
pain on palpation of that
anatomic ***** box so when we
look at our metacarpal fracture
the next fracture we're
talk about it's actually
the most common hand injury
and the mechanism is a
direct blow to the hand and
this is commonly known as
a boxer's fracture so on
physical exam the deformity
could be seen at the metacarpal
base you could also see
some shortening of the
fractured metacarpal but you
typically don't see any
motor defects it's more just
pain and maybe visual
inspection if you look down here
it typically is seen in
those fourth and fifth
metacarpals where more of the
impact could be occurring.
I want to quickly
talk about something
called fight bite. And
as you guys will learn,
the human mouth is
actually very, very
disgusting when we
think about pathogens.
So this is actually an injury
when we see potentially
a clenched fist that strikes
a tooth and could rupture
the metocarpal phalangeal
joint, the MCP joint. And
essentially, we have organisms
from a human mouth invade
that MCP. and the causes can
be an inadvertent contact
right so if you're fighting
someone or you're in a
boxing match and you accidentally
hit them in the mouth
or it could be a human bite
that's on purpose because
some people are very
strange. Some of the common
pathogens we can think about
are streptococcus viridians,
group A strep, staph aureus,
and N canca corrodins as well.
And here's an image here
again you want to be on top
of these any individual comes
in who was in a fight and
you examine their hands
for any open cuts, you have
to presume that this is
potentially an open mouth wound
until proven otherwise and
treat prophylactically.
A ganglion cyst, also
known as a Bible cyst,
is essentially just a
fluid-filled swelling
overlying the joint or
tendon sheath, and the fluid
is typically from the
joint or the tendon sheath
itself. The mechanism, it
could be a couple different
ones. It could be a trauma.
It also could just be
synovial herniation and
actually the most common
location is on the dorsal
aspect of the wrist it's
typically painless but the
key identifying factor to
differentiate it from
other you know solid bumps
or solid tumors is that
this ganglion cyst will
transilluminate or if you
shine a light you can see
through it on physical exam
there's really no indication
for removal there's
usually a spontaneous
resolution for most of these
however if it remains or if
there's any troublesome
symptoms, you can do an
aspiration or a surgery to
remove the ganglion cyst.
We are now going to
move on to the hand.
So the first pathology
we're going to talk about is
trigger finger, and this
is actually a presentation
where the finger will catch
and lock when it's flexed.
It's actually caused by
stenosing tenosynovitis
of the flexor tendons. So
we're going to see pain and
catching whenever that
finger is flexed, and it
actually may get locked into
a position of flexion. The
mechanism, you'll actually
have mechanical impingement
at the level of the A1
pulley of the hand. Don't
worry about identifying
that or even understanding
what it is, but if you're
curious, it's that pulley
right here. So when we
have normal gliding of the
tendons that is disrupted,
it could lead to increased
resistance. As the tendon
pulls through that A1 pulley,
it could lead to that
tendon actually being
entrapped. So essentially
what we can think about with
this is that the normal
movement is a little bit
disrupted and the tendon
gets trapped in a position of
flexion and once it is flexed
the affected finger could
remain locked due to
mechanical impingement and
actually one of the risk
factors of this is diabetes.
Mallet finger is going to
be the next pathology we
discuss and the presentation
here is going to be prolonged
flexion of the distal
interphalangeal joint. The
mechanism is going to be a
finger deformity caused by
disruption of the terminal
extensor tendon distal to
the DIP. And it usually
could be due to a blow to
the distal tip of the digit,
causing a rupture of the
tendon, as we see down here,
or it also could be caused
by an avulsion fracture of
that distal interphalangeal
aspect, right? So we
essentially lose our extensor
tendon. And the treatment
here we could do is
splinting. And just to think
about, if we lose our extensor
tendon, our finger will
be in prolonged flexion
because there's no counteraction
to that flexion force.
So moving on to
carpal tunnel, our
mechanism here is going
to be entrapment of
the median nerve in
the carpal tunnel.
And again, this carpal tunnel
consists of the foramen
between the transverse carpal
ligament and the carpal
bones, as you can see
over here. And this carpal
tunnel, this entrapment
could also be due to a lunate
dislocation, one of our carpal
bones. For presentation,
it's going to be paresthesia,
pain, numbness in
the distribution of the
median nerve, which is again
going to be essentially
the first three digits and
the lateral side of four.
The theonar eminence will
also be atrophied, but
sensation remains intact, and
this is actually because the
muscles are controlled by
the median nerve, but the
palmar cutaneous branch of
the median nerve enters
the hand externally to the
carpal tunnel, so that sensation
in the theonar eminence
is spared. On physical
exam, two specific tests,
the Tenelle sign, which
is percussion of the
wrist that causes
tingling, or the Phelan
maneuver, which is
bilateral flexion of the
wrists causing tingling,
some associations,
you know, maybe some buzzwords
to think about. So this
could be associated with
pregnancy due to increased
edema, rheumatoid arthritis,
hypothyroidism, diabetes,
acromegaly, and amyloidosis,
and also just repetitive
use, so anyone who's constantly
flexing their wrists.
So again, here's our
Phelan test. We're going
to see simultaneous
flexion of the wrists, and
that could cause tingling.
Tenel sign, think of
the TNT. We're going
to tap on that carpal
tunnel, and here's just an
image of that DNR atrophy
that could be a result
of the carpal tunnel.
For Goyen Canal Syndrome,
the mechanism here is going
to be compression of the
ulnar nerve at the wrist,
and it also can be due to a
hook of a handmaid fracture.
For presentation, it's
classically seen in cyclists
due to pressure at the
wrist. Motor symptoms here
could be due to muscles
affected by the ulnar nerve
innervation. So we think
here it's going to be the
intrinsic muscles of the
hand. So we have decreased
hand grip and clawing of
the fourth and fifth digits.
We also see hypothenar
atrophy as well.
So when we compare Goyang
Canal Syndrome to Cubital
Tunnel Syndrome, both
are affected with the
ulnar nerve. In Goyang
Canal Syndrome, will have
normal function of the
extrinsic or forearm
muscles supplied with the
ulnar nerve, so we shouldn't
see any issues here with
flexion of the wrist
since the ulnar nerve
innervates flexor carpi
ulnaris and flexor digitorum
profundus. However,
in cubital tunnel
syndrome, we will see these
two muscles, the flexor
carpi ulnaris and flexor
digitorum profundus be
affected because it's
a more proximal issue
with the ulnar nerve.
We are finally at our last
two pathologies we're going
to speak about, the first
one being Dequervian's
tenosynovitis, and I'm going
to lecture about this because
I was actually asked a
couple times on my rotations
about some of these ligaments
and what the special
test was, so I feel like it's
a little bit more prevalent
than some people may expect.
So the mechanism here
is a thickening of the
abductor pollicis longus and
extensor pollicis brevis
tendons again i threw a
little mnemonic up here don't
get mad at me chat gpt did
the best it could with
creating something on the fly
due to and this is typically
due to excessive friction
trauma or inflammation the
abductor pollicis longus
and extensor pollicis brevis
usually will rub on the
extensor retinaculum
creating this irritation of
the tendons and we commonly
see this actually in new
parents as a result of the
increased friction from
holding their child, typically
with the thumb extended
out. We can also see it in
racket sports and golfers.
Presentation, you're going
to see pain at the radial
styloid and swelling. For
physical exam, and this is
very important, you're going
to perform the Finkelstein's
test, where essentially
you're going to form a
fist around your thumb and
then ulnarly deviate or
move your hand down kind
of towards your pinky. If
there's pain anywhere in
kind of that area of where
those two tendons are, it's
a positive test. And for
treatment, it's essentially
just going to be a splint.
Our final pathology is
going to be tendon sheath
infection, more specifically
septic flexor tenosynovitis.
So our pathophysiology
here is going to be an
infection of the synovial
sheath that surrounds the
flexor tendon, typically
due to a penetrating trauma
of the tendon sheath. And
your presentation here
is going to be the cannibal
signs so there's going
to be four of them flex
posturing of the digit
tenderness to palpation over
the tendon sheath mark pain
with extension of the
digit and then fusiform
swelling of the joint for
treatment we're going to think
about antibiotics and
also surgery to clean and
irrigate the infected tendon
so we're now at practice
questions i'm going to go
through each one of them
but there's nothing new
that will be discussed here
that we haven't already
gone over in the lecture.
50-year-old man reports
pain near the thumb side
of his wrist. There's
also visible swelling near
the base of the thumb.
Patient mentions it's
hard to pick up objects
and grasp them with the
help of his thumb. The doctor
suspects the thickening
of the abductor pollicis
longus and extensor
pollicis brevis tendons.
Which of the following
would be a good test to
confirm this suspicion?
Again, reading this, we're
kind of thinking this
could be a decoravion
tenosynovitis, right? Abductor
pollicis longus, extensor
pollicis brevis tendons,
and knowing this the most
sensitive test here would
be D Finkelstein's test
again that's going to be
putting stress on those
two tendons and if we think
they're irritated it should
show you know an increased
pain to increase tension
on them question two a six
-year-old girl arrives to
the local urgent center
after falling in the park
she's holding her arm in
pain and pointing at the
distal humerus when asked
where it is most painful x
-ray is taken and the results
are shown which of the
following arteries are most
likely to be damaged based
on the patient's injury.
So again, we're looking
here, if we can kind of
look towards here, maybe it
looks like a supracondylar
issue based off of the
position of the fracture.
So kind of assuming
this, looking at the
x-ray, we would
assume the most likely
artery involved is
going to be the brachial
artery. Question three, 45
-year-old man presents the
clinic with a two-month
history of shoulder pain
that is worth overhead
activity, especially bothersome
at night. On exam, he
complains of pain to palpation
just below the acromion.
Empty can test is positive.
You suspect he has torn
his supraspinatus. If
correct, which of these
functional maneuvers would you
expect to be deficient on
physical exam? So what do
you think it's external
rotation, initiation of
abduction, completion of
abduction, internal rotation,
or circumduction. So again,
this kind of is a second
-order question. We need to
think about what the issue
of the supraspinatus is and
what it does. So external
rotation, not necessarily
right. We could think
of our infraspinatus and
teres minor with some of
the external rotations. I
know supraspinatus likes to
do abduction, but maybe I
don't remember which one.
Internal rotation, no,
that's our subscapularis.
And circumduction, we
didn't really speak about.
So now we're between
these two. If you remember
that little chart, the
completion of abduction
is fairly overhead,
and that's more of a,
you know, non-supraspinatus
or even non-deltoid.
We think more about traps
and serratus anterior.
So the correct answer
here is going to be B,
initiation of abduction.
Question 4, 40-year-old
male presents the ED
after falling off a
ladder while fixing the
roof of his home. Reports
to falling with his
weight on top of his
arm. X-ray shown below.
What deficits can be
observed on physical exam?
So again, I'm looking at
this x-ray. I'm fairly
certain this is probably
a mid-shaft fracture
of the humerus, right?
So if I'm thinking about
that, then my next
question is, okay, what's
my most likely issue
with nerves and arteries?
If I go through my
mnemonic of A, R, M, right?
A for axillary, R for
radial, M, I'm mid-shaft,
so that's going to
be my R, I'm thinking
radial nerve. So I'm at
that point, now I just
need to remember what
the radial nerve does.
So inability to flex
the wrists. No, that's
more like our median
and ulnar nerve.
Inability to extend the
wrist. I kind of like that
answer. Loss of sensation
to the fourth and fifth
digit. Again, that's more
of our ulnar nerve. Loss
of sensation over the
nanar eminence. That you'll
see maybe more with like
some median nerve issues.
And inability to abduct
the arm. That's going
to be more with our
axillary and the deltoid.
So the correct answer
here is going to be B.
Inability to extend the
wrist because of a radial
nerve injury from a mid
-shaft humerus fracture.
Question 5. 48-year-old
female accountant presents
to the orthopedist
regarding her wrist pain.
States towards the end of
the day, she feels shooting
nerve pain with numbness.
Pain is particularly
worse at night. On physical
exam, doctor noticed
she has noticeable thenar
atrophy, but sensation is
spared. The nerve that's
most implicated in this
disease process this runs
under what structure? So
this goes back to
understanding the surrounding
neurovascular and also
just anatomical structures
when we think about
pathology. So based
off this vignette, we
probably think this
is some form of
carpal tunnel, right?
Especially the key here
being the noticeable in our
atrophy, but sensation is
spared. So if you want to think
about what is the kind of
route or the issues around
the carpal tunnel, and it's
actually going to be B,
flexor retinaculum,
which is another
term for the transverse
carpal ligament.
Question 7. 30-year
-old female presents
to the clinic complaining
of wrist and hand
pain, states the pain
started about two
weeks ago, and she's
36 weeks pregnant.
Percussion over the
volar aspect of the wrist
elicits pain and tingling
of the first three
digits. A neurological
exam sensation is spared
over the theonar muscles,
which nerve results
and spared sensation in
this given condition.
All right, so a little
bit of a curveball here,
right? We need to think
about kind of what the
issue is at hand. This
individual is pregnant,
and this kind of test
they're talking about here
somewhat seems to be
the Tunnel sign, right?
Pain in those first three
digits. Okay, this is carpal
tunnel. And they're actually
asking about the sensation.
So if you remember back
to the lecture, it's
actually a branch of the median
nerve that kind of branches
off before, and the name
of that nerve is going to
be C, the palmar cutaneous
branch of the median nerve.
Question 8. Three-year
-old male has decreased use
of the left elbow after
his mother grabbed his
arm and attempted to leave
him across the street.
Fiscal exam demonstrates
guarding of the extremity with
slightly flexed and prone
-hitted arm, elbow swelling,
and vocal tenderness. What's
the most likely reason
for this presentation? So
again, we kind of need to
understand what is going on
here from the demonstration
and kind of what it's
talking about. I'm thinking
nursemaid's elbow here. So
what's the underlying reason
for a nursemaid's elbow?
Is it a fractured scaphoid?
Probably not. That's
not necessarily the
presentation, right?
It's more distal.
Clavicular dislocation?
They didn't really
talk about anything
with tenting or anything
like that. So no.
Clavicular fracture?
Similarly, they didn't
really talk about
anything with you know
maybe shoulder droop or
any tenting again. Mid
shaft humeral fracture
again I'd expect
more issues with
potentially you know
radial nerve extension
not really talking
about that here.
Sublux radial head nursemaid's
elbow that kind of explains
the presentation and
also the mechanism of the
injury so our correct
answer is going to be E.
Here's a summary slide for you
guys and here are my references
And that's the end
of this slideshow and
presentation. If you guys
have a little bit of time
please leave some lecture
feedback. This is one
of my first lectures
I've been developing and
I really hope to hear
some of your feedback.
And again guys if you
have any questions or
concerns regarding this
lecture please feel free to
reach out or if you see
me around campus feel free
to pull me aside. I hope
you guys are all doing
well. I wish you guys
the best of luck on your
comps and keep on pushing
through the end of this
semester. First year of
medical school is really
really hard so give you
guys a lot of credit.
Have a great day and
thank you guys again.